[Music]
in for data news submitted by saintly
Turtles so you can have you know they
use paper straws here don't great yay
thanks to sip matcha that was a plastic
one my mushy straw [ __ ] mush cuz it
what is not plastic she's giving us
credit scientists created a pill that
allows you to track fart development in
real time on your phone
why so you don't worry you don't know so
you know when a farts developing so that
you could go to the back you I could
feel the fart happening and I'm like
you're not coming out [ __ ] it's
before the fields Wow like you have T
minus 34 minutes before you fart before
you even get that feeling yeah what if
feels like that then you could plan out
your farts creation of the technology
being used here this is 2019 no flying
cars but we can track your first yeah
amazing
humans are amazed you just put this
device in your anus and then it's like a
pacifier before your eyes people would
like it too much why are people good
marketing good for marketing alright so
a group of Australian researchers have
developed an ingestible electronic
capsule to monitor gas levels in the
human gut and it's paired with a
pocket-sized receiver any mobile phone
mobile phone app popular phone the pill
reports can tell wind conditions in real
time retail wind conditions that they
called it until we scary it's just
another ploy for the government yeah
where you are yeah yes in there so
they're saying that they can use this to
track like how different types of food
affect you and like what nutrition
you're getting out of your food and all
that stuff and so they're saying that in
the trials and the human trials people
were ingesting this pill and so it had a
head it's a gas sensing capsule and so
it's to better understand
optional aspects of the intestine and
the micro micro biota and help and so
it's all around dietary changes so what
happens if I what if I what if I take
the pill in the morning and then I have
my morning coffee and then have to [ __ ]
well it takes about two days for it to
go through really good day oh so like
travels through do what if that's the
Magic School Bus that's a microphone and
then you [ __ ] [ __ ] that thing out
yeah this is where the cat like it's
reading that's like a piece of metal
that you're soloing this yeah it also
has batteries
okay wait that's [ __ ] pill to swallow
like a horse pill and this is the
receiver what the flies that look so
long no I think that's a difficult thing
a swallow
yeah a turian know that for farting
would you be down to swallow this pill
it seems like a lot of work for
something that don't matter
oh yeah no it does matter for research
pretty interesting concept like if you
could see exactly how food affects you
can't you just [ __ ] in a bag or give it
to the doctor so they could like I'm not
dissected and look at it and see what
they needed so they're saying that in
order to get the same data that they're
trying to get with this pill it is a
very invasive invasive assuming it sound
like a tube up your ass and like go
through all your intestines to get the
same kind of data here but because this
is just a simple little pill you can
swallow and like pass it through and
track it with an app and then your
doctor can can really look at what
dietary changes are happening and like
how it affects your actual body yeah so
then they're saying that if this
continues to get developed that maybe in
the future in order to check your vital
signs it or like when you go to a
hospital visit they'll check your vital
signs and ask you to swallow this
electron
muttering monitoring device to really
take your health I already know how I'm
gonna market this how I'm just gonna
upgrade the sex industry like crazy
because I'm gonna sell this to
high-class escorts cuz I'll be like how
many business deals did you ruin by
farting in front of your date I checked
your phone as the queef and then that's
sexing horny mm-hmm well you cover your
mouth in a cute way but what the
commercial would be like checkmate
checkmate
we'll have a commercial like has this
ever happened to you and it's like super
high class date and [ __ ] and then she's
like escorting and they're like laughing
and she rips one goes oh and then there
goes you're saying she's gonna do this
when she farts like they're very like no
there's no rolls-royce and [ __ ] and
she's farting they go on the yacht and
they're partying and then she's far away
he goes has this happened to you
is it greens like yeah she goes now you
could control your farts escorts I don't
have a name for control it or you know
something so then so then the the
solution part would be like each other
Rolls Royce yeah she knows like oh [ __ ]
- [ __ ] in ten minutes I gotta go she
dives in what's a snorkel in her butt
[Laughter]
view this article that they're
developing these pills to make your
farts smell really nice I don't mind
sometimes really nice huh you're the
kind of person that farts and then
leaves the Rope rolls up the windows
like hold on let me roll up if I took
this I would want to take it two times
why one time I eat crazy jumps oh they
did you that and then do that every low
fiber high fiber oh and the next time I
do something super clean and just to see
like what it reads what my levels there
are human trials they had a person so
they're saying that in one they had one
person gulp the pill twice the first
time he ate a very high fiber diet which
was 50 grams a day for two days the
hospital I heard - swallowing the pill
and then two weeks later he gulped
another pill after eating a low fiber
diet which was 15 grams per day for two
days and in the high fiber test the man
passed the pill in about 23 hours but he
had a lot of abdominal pain because of
the super high dose of fiber it was
causing a lot of o2 levels and and then
in the low fiber scenario the pill took
more than three days to work its way out
I spent 13 hours in the stomach 5.5 in
the small intestine and 54 hours in the
colon and so over double they're saying
that 36 hours after taking the pill the
man was giving given a high dose of
fiber to try to move things along but
prior to the fiber intervention h2 gas
levels in the colon had plummeted which
suggested a drop-off and fermentation
and then pick back up 12 hours after the
fiber treatment and then that's when
they passed it damn that's why they say
eat your fiber yeah you're gonna get
constipated and you're gonna have
stomach problems but the super high
fiber though like the extreme was not
good because it's hurting from too much
fart it was too much yeah what is it
what I think Oh - OH - yeah I don't even
know what too much isn't too little is
me I just eat I just try to remind
myself get that cabbage man too much
apparently for this 50 grams a day yeah
that's a lot for two days yeah that's an
average the average recommended is a 30
to 35 now cuz the low was 15
yes of 50 grams is more than what's
recommend and gaining a gram of fiber
and whole food
is like hard as a Hale what do you
what's your go-to for fiber my goats
don't I don't eat as much fiber as I
should but I try to get at least one
big-ass dose of kimchi a day and I try
to do one big-ass pile of greens a day
so but but this one as I do skip but I
only eat greens like every other day but
you're supposed to eat like a [ __ ] ton
of greens two to three servings a day
does barn end up stinking the whole
house with his scrunchie he's been
really good yeah this is pinchy not much
fart oh I like this sorry I like the UM
I like the kimchi - so oh you like
kimchi no okay so here's the thing
I love the way kimchi tastes and smells
on its own yeah
same thing with garlic same thing with
ginger that and its own great and onion
it smells by I mean I don't like to eat
onion but whatever smells fine in its
own but whenever KC will ingest it his
body oh I think it's a Asian thing
because sometimes I hear I smell Jo it
smell the same way but like it's like
ferment so different particularly it
leaves your pores yeah and like you just
enough like Melling intense so where I'm
like mmm I asked casing like please
please please if you're gonna eat and
like a crazy amount of garlic or kimchi
or ginger or onion then just sleep in
the office and close the door and open
the window because we're gonna stink up
the entire house oh you're right
I'll have Korean barbecue and eat the
raw garlic and all that and I'll go to
sleep even after I shower and the next
day I smell my room and I'm like did I
produce that jet it smells pungent
somewhat brushing your teeth and like
using mouthwash and everything I've
gotten that because it comes from here
do I do I smell like kimchi man after um
cuz I saw my mom like she eats kimchi
too and I've smelled her and I'm like
kimchi mom that's interesting I wonder
if there's any correlation to that and
the thing that I have because I have
this thing called SIBO and it's like a
bacterial overgrowth in your small
intestine and I'm not allowed to eat
garlic onion or kimchi I can have ginger
but not those three because it emits
something that the bacteria feeds on and
it makes me super bloated I've never
smelled anyone that's non-asian that's
smelled that way so that's why I equated
it to agent the same way how Asians have
difficulty breaking down alcohol so I
thought it was maybe something yeah
related in that she has her scientist
hat on
yeah yeah she does sounds a bit racist
to me that's when you can't say it's an
Asian thing I don't know you would
disagree yeah I don't know I mean I
don't know non Asian guys that eat those
three ingredients the way that we do
sighs Joe Rogan yeah Asian guys oh yeah
you might smell like an Asian dude and
like garlic and like even if it's not
raw garlic zyi raw garlic that's what
can even crazier but then I'll have
likes you know like if I cook with
garlic it comes out my pores differently
I wonder what it is
[Music]
[Music]